Dave Chappelle is being raided and
attacked by transgender activists here
he explains
so I get to the show that night and of
course protesters came uh what a thing
Mary you wouldn't believe it these were
grown people of various genders and
gender identities they threw eggs they
threw eggs that the people were lined up
to see the show oh yeah they was doing
all that one lady was so mad with the
protesters she picked up a police
barricade they never seen it looked like
a bike rack just picked that barricade
up by herself
and threw it at the crowd I got to tell
you it's an amazing feat of strength for
a woman
so it really sounds like an an exciting
scene as Chappelle goes on he says
trying to silence a person like me I
don't think it has anything to do with
being loved they want to be feared if
you say this then we will punish you
we'll come to First Avenue and F your
show up and we'll come to The Varsity
Theater and F your show up and they just
don't get to do that
Dave's describing this Behavior he says
man this is a crazy behavior
why are they doing this he says he's
trying to think of it really rationally
he says well they're doing because they
want Power I'm sure that's true and
they're doing because they want to
intimidate me and shut me up yeah I'm
sure that's true you know why else
they're doing it do you know why else
these transgender activists are behaving
like crazy people in public
crazy people
sometimes the simplest answer really is
the best and the most persuasive
these are very very crazy people if you
are a man and you think that you're a
woman you're a you're a very crazy
person and you need psychological help I
know I'm not saying that to be mean to
anybody or to make anybody feel small or
belittled but you have serious problems
if you think that and you need to go get
help
because if you don't get help if you
indulge these delusions you're just
gonna act crazier and crazier
so what do we do about this
what do we do about crazy people
generally you know the the Britney
Spears conservatorship
was a real Illuminating incident
on this kind of a question
because
we didn't know exactly how to react we
also didn't have perfect information is
Britney Spears really having
psychological problems is she totally
fine and she's just being kept a
prisoner because of her corrupt and
greedy father or that we we didn't
really quite know
but there was there was an even deeper
question which is well let's say she is
kind of crazy she should she really be
under a conservatorship or should she be
free to act as crazy as she wants
we've come to another fork in the road
here
which way are you going to go
the the squishes and the libs and our
society for the last 50 years has said
hey if you're crazy and you're in deep
distress and you have trouble
functioning in society and you can't
really take care of yourself and
that's your problem
you still have a right
to do whatever you want to do you want
to go dance around throwing eggs in the
air at a Dave Chappelle show that's
totally fine you want to go live on the
street and do a bunch of drugs down on
Skid Row that's totally fine you want to
have public meltdowns everywhere that's
your right to do it because of your
bodily sovereignty and autonomy and
self-ownership or whatever
but the conservative response is no if
if you are not in possession of your
rational faculties if you do not have a
properly functioning rational will
then not only do you not have a right to
be left alone and do whatever you want
you don't have the capacity to do that
you don't have the ability to do that
you see this in the in the big divide
over insane asylums
for
pretty much all of world history we had
insane asylums for people who were
too crazy to take care of themselves
then in the middle of the 20th century
we decided to close down all of the
insane asylums
and we did that probably with good
intention because they're not
particularly Pleasant places because
mental illness is deeply unpleasant and
very scary and because we thought well
we've got drugs now to treat this so
people don't need to be kept in these
asylums problem is though you let the
people out they stop taking the drugs
and they behave like crazy people
and then we not only indulge Mental
Illness but in recent years we've come
to to exalt it we've come to praise it
we've come to reward mental illness now
mental illness carries a cachet people
especially young people will will brag
about having a mental illness
it gives you some extra
intersectionality points well I'm not
black I'm not gay I'm not a Muslim I'm
not I don't have any of these well at
least I I'm mentally ill at least I can
say well I need to focus on my mental
health that's that's a phrase that
people use now as casual conversation
that would not have been the case even
10 years ago no one would have been
bragging about saying oh I've got a lot
of mental illnesses I say oh bro we got
to get you help
so so where do we go from here
until the conservatives are willing to
reassert
a sane Vision on society and willing to
wield political power to cultivate that
that sane
sensibility in society
until we reopen some insane asylums
until we put some restrictions on how
crazy people behave out in public until
we until we acknowledge and enforce
certain norms and standards like saying
boys or boys and girls or girls and if
you're a boy then you can't pretend to
be a girl in public that's weird stuff
and we're going to put you in
psychiatric treatment if you do that
until we start until we start wielding
that kind of political power
Dave Chappelle is going to get more eggs
in the face right now go to puretalk.com
enter promo code Knowles if one of your
goals this year is to do business with
companies that share the things that you
believe in then you got to check out
Pure Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to
woke wireless companies it is proudly
veteran owned employs a us-based
customer service team which is huge by
the way and refuses to spend money on
fake news networks not to mention Pure
Talk service is fantastic it's one of
the largest networks in the country you
can get blazing fast data talk and text
for as low as 30 a month that is
probably half of what you're paying
right now
might be less than what half of what
you're paying right now to Verizon ATT
T-Mobile switch over to puretalk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone and your phone number your first
month is guaranteed risk-free try it if
you're not completely happy with the
service you'll get your money back this
year make it a goal to support companies
that support you go to puretalk.com
enter promo code Knowles kwlas to save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless speaking
of Psychiatry new research there's a new
study
you remember yesterday if you listened
to the show yesterday I talked about how
there's there's so often new studies
that have the shocking news that our
Common Sense was right all along but
because we live in a scientistic age we
only believe things when they come in
studies and when they've got lots of
statistics and peer-reviewed clinical
numbers in them to tell us things that
we knew the whole time well here's the
new shocking study
anti-depressant drugs
can dull your emotions
this is the headline is it
anti-depressant drugs do what they say
that they will do
they blunt your emotions
but not just in the good way not just in
the way that they're sold in the
commercials also in the bad way
they not only these drugs not only
make your depressive periods less severe
they also make your Joys less
exciting they make your your Joys less
joyful
quote emotional blunting is a common
side effect of SSRI antidepressants
according to Professor Barbara sahakyan
at the University of Cambridge in a way
this may be in part how they work yeah
exactly they take away some of the
emotional pain that people who
experience depression feel but
unfortunately it seems that they also
take away some of the enjoyment
I hate these drugs
I don't have personal experience with
them I know that some people write in
they say antidepressant drugs were very
helpful to me or they saved my life I'm
not saying that there's no application
for them ever in any case
but for the vast majority of people who
are on these drugs right now and who are
on these drugs for a long period of time
it is a bad idea
and part of the reason
that people are are constantly being
prescribed these drugs
is because it's big money
antidepressants are a 17 billion dollar
a year industry they're set to grow to a
22 billion dollar per year industry by
2027. and here's here's how I know
that too many people are on these drugs
that probably most people on these drugs
should never touch these things
13 of American adults take
antidepressant drugs
13 percent
and when you just look at women
the number goes up to 18 percent one in
five women in our country
regularly takes depression drugs
that is not here is a medical
intervention to maybe get you through a
particularly difficult period to then
allow psychological or religious
intervention to come in and help
ameliorate your problem no that is just
drug addiction
there is no way that it's just a fact of
the human condition that one in five
women needs to be on these insane
expensive powerful drugs that blunt your
experience of humanity that is a
national Scandal that is evil and it's
nothing new exactly
specifically with the women
for all of human history we have been
trying to cure women of Womanhood
there are all these interventions that
we've had to cure women of the
eccentricities that go along with being
women before we applied them all with
with zombie drugs we we went in and
scrambled up their brains we gave them
lobotomies in the middle of the 20th
century before that we had all sorts of
creative imaginative treatments for
hysteria
for for going back actually to the
ancient world
we're always trying to cure women of
being women
and now we're trying to cure Humanity of
any sense of suffering
but suffering is a sanctifying thing
and
if you
if you are constantly throughout your
whole life reliant on some very powerful
psychology altering drug mind altering
drug to deal with that something has
gone wrong and maybe there are even a
handful of people who really need that
kind of intervention you know it's a
Fallen World some people have really
severe problems
one in five Americans
no I don't think so I think that is a
national Scandal and the more we've
learned about big Pharma over the years
the the less and less likely I am to
give them the benefit of the doubt and
the more I hope Republicans start
pushing on this not just on the covet
vaccines but on this Scandal that we are
applying a fifth of the population
in in certain cases at least 13 percent
with very expensive powerful drugs to
take to deprive them of beautiful
aspects of their Humanity the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it because sometimes Mr Davies and
the producers over there they get very
very upset because they say I want you
to talk about this story I say I don't
know I don't want to talk about that
story I want Michael and you I want to
hear you talk about that Sam listen I
got to focus on important things I got
to talk about the sexy green Eminem okay
I can't I don't have time for so they
have found a story that I've not gotten
to this week they they want my expert
opinion on it become a member right now
use code Knowles kwels a checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign